let me go to cass from edmonton
uh cass from edmonton what's going on
hey david can you hear me you're coming
through loud and clear
perfect awesome i'm from yeah i'm from
edmonton as you know i've actually been
watching the show for almost 10 years
now and wow
that's long ago i've been doing it
somehow you were watching the show
before
eight years like everyone since high
school that's all i know like it feels
like a decade
awesome but um feels like 40 years to me
so
all right but it actually inspired me to
take political science in school which
i'm doing right now
and and what we're learning about and
something i thought was interesting
in joe biden's town hall is about
kind of the decline of the united states
as a hegemony
and the rise of china and more
specifically
the united states has loss of soft power
and i was really interested in what joe
biden had to say
to the republican when talking about
foreign policy and i thought he kind of
touched on this
um previously this is kind of a
right-wing talking point or do you know
even trump's like
anti-china how do you think that the
democrats
moving forward could address the unit
like the united states soft power
issues and kind of strengthening
themselves on the world stage
so there's really specific analysis that
could be done there
that relates to you know as micro as
looking at
where manufacturing and energy
industries are moving globally like that
they would almost be like industry
analyses but i think that we have
fallen so out of favor globally under
donald trump
that there's a much broader analysis
that first has to be done which is
if you look at the three global
superpowers right now
uh us china russia you look at the role
of
india as a growing economy you look at
nigeria as an example you know and you
start to go
sort of go down the list um yeah the
first step
to even be back in the picture is we
need just
some basic things to happen a president
who doesn't think
climate change is a hoax created by the
chinese we're no longer even
part of so many of the global
conversations about climate because of
trump's position
on climate that if that doesn't get
fixed we're screwed right number two
um are our uh traditional western
democratic allies
uk germany france canada you know these
places where the relationships have
soured uh because of how donald trump
relates to other people
if that stuff doesn't get dealt with
first which i
really am moder moderately confident
that uh a biden administration would do
on policy we may disagree with them on
some of of of the geopolitics but at
least they would rehab
our image in those relationships that
has to be step
one before we can even have a more
serious conversation about what's going
to happen with china and russia in the
next 20 years
yeah 100 i agree i think it's
interesting that joe biden mentioned it
and
hopefully he can address it because i
think a lot of people on the left kind
of shy away from it
i agree bye awesome thank you
cass from edmonton thank you so much for
the uh thank you so much for the call
hope to hear from you
again in the future i want to take a
second to tell you about one of our
sponsors
s h masks s h masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and
other protective gear for covet 19 and
they're giving my audience 20 percent
off
snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five-layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol
wipes no touch infrared thermometers and
all of their prices
are very reasonable i also love snh
masks because they've donated over 60
000 masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company
shipping is just five bucks and shipping
is free
on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david